do you hate seeing sunlight and do you
love Star Wars hi I represent the Disney
Company due to circumstances beyond our
control the Galactus star Cruiser Hotel
Star Wars experience turned out to not
be a super good business financial
decision but do we have a real estate
idea property for you do you hate your
guests then if you're like Marriott or
Holiday Inn then this could be a good
property for you to have windowless room
tiny bunker what's not to love the Star
Wars hotel is currently experiencing an
infestation from theater kids they are
still in character the US government you
like you guys could use this for maybe
like for the prisoners you don't want to
see the light of day we don't need it
anymore we don't want it anymore we're
just gonna pretend like it never happens